aussi je voudrais qu'on passe à une
autre question c'est celle du figaro
aujourd'hui le mouvement mis tous at il
eu des effets positifs sur la société
c'est la question qu'on pose sur
lefigaro.fr et pour l'instant où vous
êtes une large majorité à répondre 60 à
75% très exactement à répondre non voici
en tout cas ce que on a dit marlène
schiappa qui est secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes s'étaient sur rtl ça n'a pas
bouleversé la donne parce qu'on ne peut
pas changer en un an et même si la force
de mitsou est incontestable on ne peut
pas changer en un nom des comportements
qui sont ancrées depuis des générations
le président de la république l'avait
dit à lui-même en lançant la grande
cause de son quinquennat pour l'égalité
femmes hommes
toute notre société est malade du
sexisme ça va demander beaucoup
travaillent ensemble pour faire en sorte
de guérir de cette maladie alors je veux
au site excusez moi c'est une citation
dont je vous demande bien de mettre des
guillemets ce que je vais dire une
un certain d'une chose de paroles qui
ont été tenus je cite c'est donc on
verra comment tu fais la belle avec une
jambe cassée on verra comment tu suces
quand je te déboîterai la mâchoire
t'es juste une truie tu mérites ta place
à l'abattoir t'es juste un démon déguisé
en femme
je te veux te voir brisée en larmes je
dois rendre l'âme je veux te voir
retourner brûler dans les flammes
l'auteur de ces paroles a reçu trois
victoires de la musique
c'était en février dernier et il ne me
semble pas avoir ré entendu ces paroles
à ce moment là alors qu'on se demandait
gravement s'il fallait réécrire l'issue
de la fin la finale les pilotes de la
belle au bois dormant
heureusement aussi le prince n'a pas
fait un baiser volé oui c'est assez
drôle ce qu'audi je me souviens très
bien de quelqu'un que je connais que
j'aime beaucoup ségolène royal qui
s'était insurgé contre les paroles
d'orelsan qui chantait aux francofolies
elle en avait pris plein la patate
ségolène elle s'était il a été condamné
il a été condamné en première instance
la cour d'appel de versailles en février
il faut avancer sur les combats et moi
je trouve que la rolex à n'a changé il a
fait aussi son mea culpa je veux dire
par là que le combat bits ou alors il ya
des gens qui pensent beaucoup
apparemment ça c'est moche je pense que
ce formidable ça a libéré complètement
la parole ça a permis aux gens de
s'exprimer
c'est un mouvement planétaire je lisais
que aujourd'hui il assure parce que
c'est l'anniversaire je lisais que il ya
même en chine maintenant les chinois tan
sociétés fermées il tricks et se sont
emparés de demi tout pour pourparlers
pour dénoncer vous avez des milliers de
plaintes qui ont été déposées
je trouve ça formidable de libérer la
parole des femmes va quand même s'il ya
quelques excès il faut libérer la pose
une question ce matin moi j'ai traversé
la rue pour venir ici aussi j'étais avec
mes enfants je cherchais pas du boulot
mais je fais passer de lui passer devant
les kiosques à journaux à l'intérieur il
ya moins de journaux d'ailleurs qui sont
avant parfois qu'il ya toujours les
devantures
il ya toujours des unes de magazines
pornos dessus donc rien à valence et le
port et le port de la porcherie annonce
à brega
à preuve du contraire la pornographie
est encore légalement mais il a raison
de dire ça procède d'un tout moi je
salut vincent le féministe ça pour ça
dans tout même moi je suis très heurtée
quand je vois ça mais en même temps
voilà on est quand même dans un pays de
liberté dont orelsan à droite chantier
ce qu'il chante
après c'est la justice je dormais non
mais voilà la justice temps mais je veux
dire à un moment donné d'un jeu si c'est
vrai alors là juste à définir
oui mais je vous signale la justice a
décidé mais je vous rappelle cette
polémique
terrible la personne qui a été mise en
accusation pendant des semaines c'est
ségolène pour avoir dénoncé orelsan
chantant on chante aux francofolies donc
c'est quand même une inversion de la
charge
maintenant ça change un peu mais voilà
je trouve que ça change et je trouve que
ce qui a changé vous voyez ça ça arrive
très tard par rapport à l'université
quand on entend ce qui se passait dans
les universités il ya pas si longtemps
dans les années 70 80 et que là c'est la
féminisation qu'à changer les choses
c'est à dire que ce qui se passait en
termes de bon nous employons pas le mot
droit de cuissage mais ça y ressemble
fort je pense que c'est quelque chose de
résiduel parce qu'il ya eu un
rééquilibrage notamment entre le parmi
les enseignants parmi les étudiants
aussi mais parmi les parmi les
enseignants c'était un monde d'hommes et
donc c'était un monde qui avait ses
privilèges et il ya un certain nombre de
personnes en ont abusé
encore une fois d'après as a beaucoup de
témoignages est aujourd'hui me semble
faux pas à votre prenait 6 mais il me
semble qu'il ya eu un certain équilibre
et que les équipes la mixité ont arrangé
les choses d'une manière importante au
moins un secteur après le show biz parce
que ça si vous voulez on parle du milieu
du cinéma on parle de milieux très
particulier quand on parle de la ferme
itou après la société elle est soumise à
des vents le vent des burqas qui s'ouvre
d'arabie saoudite le vent de la
pornographie kaki il s'offre d'amérique
ne m'ont pas l'air d'améliorer la
situation d'ensemble
si on s'intéresse à l'image d'affairiste
une ambition si on s'intéresse à la
manière dont un petit gars passion
aujourd'hui un petit garçon de 10 ans
aujourd'hui découvre les femmes la
sexualité à travers la pornographie je
vous laisse seul on est jeudi blesse les
raisons ce niveau
le port émissaire qu'on vous recommande
et qu'ils éditions du cerf ses 9 ans
d'ailleurs voilà le dernier vers leur
nouvelle annexe en tout cas je ne sais
pas qui est cette presse-là mais en tout
cas ça vous dire que je lui ai dit et
moi ils m'ont plus profond mépris pour
pas dire autre chose parce que ça c'est
insupportable
à tous les égards maintenant pour en
revenir à la question de fond je reviens
vraiment à la logique du temps on
apprend matic du toulon qui a comme
quand on fait une société quand on bâtit
un celi oui non mais je suis d'accord
mais simplement sur revenons à ce
qu'avait proposé monsieur blanc quelle
quantité un état il est arrivé il a dit
un projet simple que j'ai trouvé
vraiment pertinent lire écrire compter
respecter autrui
voilà je trouve qu'en 2017 qu'on soit
obligé de dire ça de rappelé à dire
c'est aussi le rôle de l'école bien
qu'on a vraiment failli nous on aurait
peut-être dû le dire il ya 60 ans et dès
le départ faire suer dans l'école je
vois un vrai facteur d'éducation parce
que dans ces cas là je pense que si on
avait appris ça peut-être qu on
respecterait mieux notre environnement
on respecte le mieux son prochain et là
on en a pour deux générations avant
d'arriver à remettre le truc sur les
rails on continuera le débat d'ailleurs
continue dans les colonnes du figaro et
dans les pages débats aussi mignon mais
pardon marque mais de le déformer et en
plus je sais que vous avez beaucoup de
choses à dire notamment sur la
pornographie
vous avez été tenu des propos très fort
j'étais là cette place effectivement un
dernier mot pour vous changer la société
et ça a changé le rapport des hommes aux
femmes
c'est une bonne chose et avec les toute
révolution provoque des effets négatifs
et il fallait en passer par là et c'est
très bien et moi je suis content d'être
un homme dans une société où la parole
des femmes s'est libérée ce qui est le
plus important c'est une mère femme qui
a obtenu le prix nobel de physique et
l'égalité salariale c'est ce que nous
dit blueberry c'est important c'est
également le baiser pas volée car reçu
marc landré de françoise degois et robes
qui nous dit je ne sais pas trop ce que
me tout mais dans la campagne l'égalité
hommes femmes est assez présente je
finis par vous recommander puisqu'en